the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
greetings if this is your first bonus
shows the david pakman show member this
is the first bonus show of march we
closed out februari Bigley last night do
we break the record oh yeah the record
for new members was broken around like
this 15 for the month that's amazing
yeah I mean February's 28 days yes
indeed februari the shortest month but a
record-setting month so welcome to all
the new members an Alabama church wants
to create its own police force which is
weird to me because you'd think that if
the power of prayer is what many believe
it to be that you wouldn't need a police
force but regardless briarwood
presbyterian church in vestavia hills
made the request to have their own
police force and it became the subject
of House Bill 180 which is being
sponsored by state representative Arnold
Mooney it's already passed the house
Public Safety Committee why would a
church need its own cops they say it's
to create a safer campus in a fallen
world it's raising some pretty major
constitutional concerns like for example
would the state have authority over this
police force if something goes wrong and
the spit and the church becomes sort of
its own jurisdiction with its own police
force does the state have authority over
that police force if the police of this
church act unlawfully in spite of having
whatever training is required who has
the power to discipline that normally
actual city municipality or state police
forces do discipline themselves
internally can any religious institution
demand its own police force do the
police have to sign statement of faith
that they align with the church's
beliefs and would that be constitutional
can you take these cops to court because
in the end of the day we are talking
about a religious institution there's
major questions about this well I think
it just sounds to me like any other type
of private police force so for example i
went to Suffolk University in Boston and
they had their own police department
there they weren't security they were
actual
certified police officers trained by the
State Police but I mean I think a lot of
people had a tough time kind of
recognizing their authority that way and
I mean there were different places where
they had jurisdiction over but of course
I think ultimately you kind of have to
yield to the Boston Police Department
well it depends so here's the deal there
are universities that have security and
there are universities that have actual
police department so as an example for a
while Smith College in Northampton
Massachusetts had a security and they
did not really have the authority to
detain people for example they would
have to call northampton massachusetts
police eventually they contracted with
an organization that actually
establishes police forces for colleges
and universities and that changed the
authority that they have the University
of Massachusetts Amherst has police that
has equivalent authority to
Massachusetts State Police in their
public school so that's a little bit
different different because it's a
public school as well yes so there's a
number of different questions here and
when it comes to Authority yeah there
was a time when people would sort of be
aware that Smith College security can't
actually make you do anything they can't
make you stay if they say you need to
stay here and wait for the police to
arrive they don't actually have the
authority to physically detain you now
they now they do so this is this creates
a lot of it creates more questions than
the number that it answers let me put it
that way I mean especially giving the
religious angle and if that's even
constitutional or not because I mean in
exchange for this I don't know if it's
501 C 3 or whatever tax-exempt status
the churches have yeah in this country
they're supposed to not even be involved
in any politics right and yet we see
them break that law all the time they're
always talking about abortion and you
know sometimes even pastors will endorse
particular political candidates and
there's really no repercussions over
that rarely r if they're able to do that
I would imagine they'd be able to have
their own police force even though at
some points that may conflict with the
the state or the town police forces
there's a lot of looking the other way I
think is what you're getting at with
regard to religious institution so we'll
see what happens in will report back to
you okay you can measure
the average distance to the closest
forest right so no matter where you are
in the u.s. you can measure how far you
are from the closest for us and then you
can take an average of all that and say
okay on average in the United States
here is the distance to the closest
forest over the last several decades
city populations have gone up and
Americans have moved away from forests
but we're also now seeing that the
forests are moving away from Americans
there's a new study done by satellite
images over 10 years starting in
nineteen ninety which shows that the
rural forest canopy is disappearing
forest space is disappearing from the
United States in pretty big chunks such
that the average distance from any point
on in the United States to the closest
forest has increased by fourteen percent
which is about a third of a mile now
third of a mile might not sound like a
lot but when you consider that this is
an average of all points in the United
States if you're driving a car what's
the difference if you're driving an
extra third of a mile to get to the
closest forest but when you think about
all of the birds that are around for
example and the fact that every single
bird now has to travel further to get
back to a forest and the implications
that that has on pollinators and so many
other aspects this is another way that
we can measure what is happening on to
the environment in our planet and I know
a lot of people this is we're doing a
story on the bonus show because there's
many people who just would not even
really care or understand why this is a
big deal but this is showing the
fundamental change that the topography
of our planet is actually experiencing
yeah and usually these tree issues get
focused in cities because sometimes
they'll be a tree that's in danger of
falling over and hitting a house or a
power line and that gas they get taken
down and there's usually some uproar
about it right or if they're putting in
some new shopping center and they have
to take down trees but that's the vast
majority of this issue comes into play
when you talk about rural areas because
you know most people do live in
cities and suburban areas but if you go
through the middle of the country the
vast majority of the area in this
country is just middle America right
rural areas a lot of trees a lot of
vegetation and some of the other ways
that this can be a can affect sort of
daily life is forests retract you will
just mathematically get more bears who
end up outside of the forest and what do
they do when they get outside of the
forest they often get confused and they
wander close to where people are living
that's not something that most people
want bears in their backyards when you
think about carbon sequestration right
trees take carbon out of the atmosphere
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
when the forestry track you limit the
ability of the forest to sequel
sequester as much carbon so this makes a
really big difference most of the people
who watch our show probably get
intuitively if not specifically why this
is such a big deal and it's always
interesting to me when you can get a
really specific number that tells you
like hey we've measured how bad X
problem is and here's how bad it is and
fourteen percent is really a lot right I
think you can kind of look at what the
problem is there I mean a lot of it has
to do with population growth so in 1990
the population of the u.s. was 250
million now it's almost 320 million
right and not only are there more people
but also there's more demand for
products things like paper and wood and
everything else so I mean that means you
have to cut down trees and a lot of the
times you're cutting down trees in the
place that's most proximus to the city
areas yes indeed yeah no doubt about it
and I've read quite a bit about these
sort of planned a sustainable
deforestation where you take down a
bunch of trees and you immediately have
to replant trees and of course it can be
20 30 or 40 years before those trees
will be ready to be taken down again or
back to the size that they were etc
takes a long time it's a long time it's
obviously better than doing nothing
there's no doubt about it but
sustainable deforestation is an
interesting topic a white football
player who participated in a violent
assault and violation of an
intellectually disabled young black man
will serve zero jail time after a trial
where his actions were determined to be
non sexual and also not based on race
specifically the race of the victim this
is john howard 18 years old who pled
guilty to his role in a violent assault
of a 17 year old black teammate the
judge awarded him nothing more than
community service and three years of
probation despite the fact that the
crime was a felony victim's parents
stormed out of the hearing before its
conclusion outraged they felt it was
incredibly unjust Howard was one of
three high school students who
participated in the assault and the
violent violation of this intellectually
disabled black man on their football
team the teens parents said that the
boys frequently victimized the student
photographing him naked hurling racial
slurs Adam making him sing racial slaw a
song racist songs about lynching and
still the boy said he considered the
teens to be his friend in October of
2015 one teen offered the boy a hug in
their Idaho locker room and while in his
embrace another teen I'm not even going
to use the full language that's used
here but let's just say that there was
anal penetration that took place
absolutely horrible what's going on here
and the attorneys representing Howard
said well the disabled team the teen was
being coached by his parents about what
to say in order to win a 15 million
dollar lawsuit against the school over
the attack and again Howard pled guilty
to the crimes and the judge decided that
the actions weren't sexual noir
influenced by race and indeed saying
that this is going to be just probation
and further the judge also said if I
thought that you had committed this
offense for racial purposes you would go
straight to the Idaho penitentiary this
sentence make sense to you of course not
I mean it's obviously sexual assault by
the letter of the law I would think I
mean they're placing a foreign object
inside of this poor kids body yeah a
coat hanger I guess in this instance
obviously I think that's that's right
pretty clearly and there's a lot of
people who say rape is never sexual it's
always about power and violence so I
don't get how now you can say well since
we don't believe it was sexual in the
sense of
being arousing to the perpetrator we're
going to consider it not to be sexual
assault that's sort of not how rape
works right i mean when else would you
apply this logic yeah i mean it's it's
really enough setting story especially
because i would imagine if there's any
case where someone should deserve
justice it's when you you attack someone
who is disabled yes and you'd think that
the judge would have some compassion for
the victim here but it sounds like he's
having compassion for the perpetrator
yeah because I mean you know it's a
young white kid 18 years old he probably
has this idea in his head that he
doesn't want to ruin the kid for the
rest of his life or ride from in jail or
any what happened to the victim you have
to focus on the victims and foremost
there was a similar story I think it was
at this point probably about a year ago
yeah about a Montana judge and a rape
sentence of like 30 days for a child
rape case okay and ultimately I don't
remember if the judge ended up having to
resign but it completely exploded and I
think they resent into the perpetrator
yeah I vaguely remember a story to I
this was big news about some swimmer a
college athlete who unfortunately raped
a girl behind a dumpster yeah and then
he didn't get any jail time I mean part
of that was had to do with the fact that
he was well off the fact that he was an
Ivy League student I think it was
Stanford right I might yeah that sounds
that sounds right yeah and uh yeah I
mean it was a there was a testimony you
could read from the girl herself
ashleigh banfield read it in its
entirety on CNN yep it was horrible and
and the kid barely face any
repercussions for whatsoever and that
one had no follow-up right i mean i
think the montana one had some kind of
repercussions either for the judge or
resentencing but from what i recall
nothing happened with the stanford one
after the sentence yeah i mean a lot of
these stories die off you kind of have
to like look into what ends up happening
to the judges and get else but it was
one of those things where the public was
not having it at all yeah alright that's
it for the bonus show please get your
coffee orders in a lot of people pat
have already reordered coffee we just
launched coffee about three weeks ago
and there are three or four people who
have already made second orders of the
coffee because they love the coffee so
much it's almost like there's an
addictive property in this product that
is causing people to come back to it
it's interesting how
work yeah david pakman.com slash gear
that is the place and you have coffee in
there today i have coffee in here made
from the Keurig i usually reusable pod
as always somebody wrote in and said
that you conveniently didn't mention
whether it's recyclable plastic that
your Keurig pot is made from I didn't
think plastic was recyclable period I
thought that was the whole problem with
plastic I mean what does it matter i'm
using it over and over and over again
you're not a growing it out so I mean
I'm reusing it right you're not throwing
it out I'm not a bad person people
demanding continued answers in Keurig
gate by the way I hope we have time for
this tomorrow but there's a new thing
called spit gate and yeah this is the
third liquid leak that's come out from
the show in the past couple weeks we had
soup gate Oh soup gate yes interrogator
again all related in liquids yeah well
let's hope that trend doesn't continue
to eventually could get pretty graphic
that's why I'm calling at least please
yeah they are less interesting it was
double on okay that's it for today get
your coffee david packing.com slash year
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
there's